[Musica]
[Applauso]
adesso immaginate un momento il momento
in cui arrivate a casa al termine della
giornata magari a tarda sera siete
stremati da una giornata di lavoro non
vedete l'ora di entrare in casa vostra
fuori a buio girate la chiave nella
serratura aprite la porta varcata la
soglia
chiudete la porta alle vostre spalle e
finalmente siete a casa il mondo resta
fuori tutti i problemi rimangono fuori i
pericoli rimangono fuori
siete nel vostro nido sia te nel nel
vostro luogo sicuro siete a casa adesso
provate un secondo ad immaginare se in
un batter di ciglia
in questo istante quel luogo il vostro
luogo sicuro diventasse il luogo
pericoloso il luogo da temere il parco
fuori di notte diventasse il luogo
sicuro questo è quello che accade quando
c'è un terremoto
il terremoto è un qualcosa di subdolo
perché non si preannunciano si può
prevedere nel momento stesso in cui
accade se ci coinvolge non possiamo fare
solo due cose sperare che finisca il
prima possibile e pregare che non ci
cada in testa nulla che ci schiaccia e
poter vedere l'alba di domani
queste cose infondono nel cuore un senso
di impotenza che fanno paura e dal punto
di vista psicologico sono devastanti nel
maggio del 2012
un terremoto ha colpito la mia terra ha
colpito queste terre e in quella
situazione così disorientata così
drammatica
un insegnante di musica della scuola del
mio paese ha deciso di mettere a
disposizione le sue competenze per dare
il suo piccolo contributo alla rete si
tura del tessuto sociale che era
completamente lacerato prese gli allievi
della scuola di musica li portò in un
luogo sicuro e gli fece suonare la
musica non era importante
la musica era un mezzo era un pretesto e
neanche gli strumenti musicali erano
importanti perché gli strumenti musicali
erano rimasti dentro la scuola di musica
che era inagibile non si potevano andare
a prendere quindi questi ragazzi
dovettero trovare materiali di fortuna
bidoni lattine bottiglie pentole tubi
qualsiasi oggetto potesse essere
percorso per ricavarne un suono e tutti
insieme cominciarono a suonare si
chiedono un nome ci diedero il nome di
banda rulli frulli e cominciarono a
suonare mentre la terra tremava e ogni
volta che il terremoto faceva tremare il
terreno sotto ai loro piedi loro
suonavano più forte perché avevano
ingaggiato questa sfida con il terremoto
che gli aveva spaventati aveva distrutto
la loro terra e questa sfida col
terremoto
piano piano dentro il cuore di questi
ragazzi cominciò a ritessere il coraggio
a dissipare la paura tre insegnanti
della scuola di musica video questo
progetto bici si appassionarono e
decisero di farne parte
e così in quattro insegnanti
cominciarono a coltivare questo progetto
a farlo crescere e molto presto si
accorsero che erano sei maestri di
questa cosa ma erano anche apprendisti
perché prova dopo prova scoprivano
quello che la musica era in grado di
tirar fuori dalle persone scoprivano un
potere sconfinato
voi provate ad immaginare la banda non
li frulli non fa niente di veramente
speciali in realtà suonano lattoni
bidoni tantissime bande prima della
banda erano lì frulli hanno suonato
strumenti ricavati da materiali
riciclati pensate solo a stomp tambur di
bronx blue man group che cos'è allora
che rende così speciale questo progetto
che lo rende così unico se io adesso vi
chiedessi di fare mentalmente
3481 per 2827 non ci proverete neanche
ma se io vi proponessi di provare farà
mente 24 per 30 24 per 30 è una sfida
che intriga che stuzzica ma perché
perché percepite che alla vostra portata
voi sentite che 24 per 30
lo potete fare quando voi andate a
teatro a vedere gli stomp si esce dal
teatro strabiliati si esce dal teatro
dicendo questi sono di un altro pianeta
io non riuscirei mai a fare una cosa del
genere io non riuscirei mai a fare una
cosa del genere
questo di te quando invece vediamo la
panda rulli frulli che suona davanti a
migliaia di persone al primo maggio a
roma ho di fianco amica nel suo
programma televisivo che cosa sentite
guardandoli che è qualcosa che alla
vostra portata
voi li guardate ditte cavolo quella cosa
lì potrei farlo anche io potrei
riuscirci c'è la potrei fare ed è questo
l'ingrediente segreto che rende il
progetto non li frulli magico che rende
questa banda qualcosa di unico che passa
il messaggio di dio ce la posso fare
infonde nel cuore di piccoli ragazzi e
anche adulti
la speranza
senza nessuna barriera di differenza voi
provate ad immaginare un collettivo in
cui qualsiasi individuo ma veramente
qualsiasi individuo potesse mettere a
disposizione le sue competenze senza
nessun tipo di barriera nessuna barriera
di genere
nessuna barriera dieta nessuna barriera
di abilità disabilità di razza mettere
in gioco le sue competenze essere
integrato ad essere messo in condizione
di sfruttare quelle competenze in modo
costruttivo in modo positivo e farli
crescere
pensate se fosse così il mondo oggi e
adesso vogliamo darvi una piccola
dimostrazione quindi chiamo sul palco
con me
federico alberghini il primo di quei
quattro insegnanti e alcuni ragazzi
della banda rulli frulli e quattro
volontari del pubblico quattro volontari
che vogliano venire qui su con noi per
aiutarci a dimostrare quello che abbiamo
appena detto cioè che questa cosa
chiunque la può fare e non solo è anche
terribilmente divertente quindi 44
persone dal pubblico su abbiamo la
scaletta li quattro volontari 4 impavidi
che si mettano in gioco per provare
questa cosa siamo qui ad una giornata
dove parliamo di imprese no 4 che
vogliono fare la loro oggi li vediamo
arrivare grandissimi un applauso ai
coraggiosi
lascia spazio alla musica grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]